mr. president seated before you are the
trustees faculty alumni candidates for
degrees and honored guests of the
University
we're here and we're all wet and that's
fine we're assembled for the annual
commencement in colombia's 250 sixth
academic year with your permission mr.
president the exercises will begin
please stand for the vocal performance
of the national anthem by joseph
goldberg of columbia college class of
2010 oh say can you see by the dawn's
early light what so proudly we hailed at
the twilight's last gleaming whose broad
stripes and bright stars through the
us fight or the ramparts we watched were
so gallantly streaming and the Rockets
red glare the bombs bursting in air
am gay
through the night that our flag was
still there
oh say does that star-spangled banner
yet wave
Eve or the land of the free
team and the mother brain
babe
the opening words will be pronounced by
Janel Davis university chaplain you can
be seated
you're columbia university degree will
identify you around the globe as among
the best educated women and men in the
world may you be of good character may
you have moral courage may you have an
open heart a discerning mind and a
generous principled spirit amen
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the university li SI Bollinger
first of all first of all I want all of
you graduates your parents family
friends who are braving this day with
you to know that I have exercised the
one executive power I have which is to
cut short key sections of today's
program
so that so that we can focus as much
time as possible on that moment you are
really here for namely when your school
is called and you receive your degree it
is no less an honor I want to say to our
remarkable honorary degree recipients
and medalists that we will not read all
that there is to say about them from the
podium but I urge you I really do urge
you to keep that page about them in the
program dry so that you can read for
yourselves what an expiring example they
lead for all of us you have had some
beautiful class days this week but
hopefully you know there is a long and
well proven folk wisdom of the Academy
that if it rains on your commencement
you are guaranteed to have a fabulous
life
so so for the next hour or so just think
about how today is your lucky day I
include I include in the editing process
my own commencement address and I was
going to give a much longer set of
remarks as an alternative we are going
to put the unabridged edition online
this afternoon
along with a little multiple-choice quiz
on it that you will have to complete
before your degree actually becomes
official so please remember your uni and
password here is the unabridged version
we care about you and we congratulate
you on what you've achieved all of us
here today are and forever will remain
part of the same community the Columbia
community there is a tradition here by
which to chart your life's course to
aspire to and to answer to this little
world you have been in idealizes the
virtues of deep and open thought and the
power of reason and human insight the
much bigger world you are entering
values that need to deal effectively
with the very real problems it has and
the opportunities to be better than it
is now the two worlds exist in parallel
each needing the other and we both need
to improve here we need to answer more
than we are now the call for help on
solving the most pressing and mystifying
issues the world has ever seen the real
world needs to embrace more of the
intellectual character we try to
practice here there are three areas of
concern the denial of expertise most
vividly and disturbingly represented in
those who would reject the consensus of
the scientific community about human
induced climate change the second the
second problem is the hardening of
beliefs and intolerance as witnessed in
the unwillingness and of many in public
discourse to at least entertain the
possibility that others may have better
ideas which inexorably leads to
intimations of violence and finally
there is the corrosive attitude now
prevalent in public debate that the less
said the better because expression
of your viewpoint can only get you in
trouble sadly represented in their
current inability to discuss and debate
with the constitution of the nation does
and should mean beyond simplicity's such
as we must follow the original intent of
the founders these three afflictions the
denial of expertise the intolerance and
the retreat into silence would be the
death of our universities and they will
be if allowed to prevail the death of
our democracy you have been steeped in
the culture of having to state your
views explain why they make sense
consider alternatives and abide by the
results of a process that transcends
your own wishes about what you would
like to believe you have plunged into
the complexities of subjects and kept
your cool now we plead with you to take
these intellectual habits of mind into
the political arena leading a new
generation in the process this is your
tradition in the midst of the beginning
of this nation when Americans had proven
themselves quite capable of taking up
arms in bloody revolt against
government's they didn't like and
informing themselves by reading a highly
partisan press filled with scurrilous
personal attacks some were able to frame
the contentious battles over the very
nature of the new federal union into a
model of coherent reasoned advocacy
through the classic Federalist Papers
and two of the three authors Hamilton
and J were Colombians and not just
not just names on those buildings over
there in the corner this is your
heritage and this is your mission to be
our new Hamilton and J the world needs
you and we send you into it with
confidence there's clearly no shortage
of work to be done congratulations and
good luck to the class of two thousand
the Provost of the University Claude M
steel will present the candidates for
the university medal for excellence and
candidates for degrees in honoris causa
please hold your applause until all
citations have been read mr. president I
have the honor to present Ron gonin for
the university medal for excellence
for helping to secure a greener future
for our planet we present you with our
alumni medal of excellence
congratulations mr. president I now have
the honor to present Dana shuts for the
university medal for excellence in
recognition of your formidable talent
and achievements as well as continuing
artistic promise we present you with our
alumni medal of excellence
congratulations data mr. president I
have the honor to present to Bing for
the degree of Doctor of Humane Letters
honoris cosas
for your ongoing artistic contributions
to our global society we present you
with a Doctor of Humane Letters honoris
casa
mr. president I have the honor to
present Geoffrey Canada for the degree
of Doctor of Laws honoris causa your
work is the real demonstration of what
it takes to leave no child left behind
and as your example ripples outward it
is changing our world for this columbia
presents you with the degree of Doctor
of Laws honoris kozlov mr. president I
have the honor to present Joel I Klein
for the doctor for the degree of Doctor
of Laws honoris causa
as Chancellor you introduce
comprehensive reforms that have turned
new york city schools into a national
model for educational innovation in
recognition of your career of public
service we are pleased to bestow upon
you a Doctor of Laws honoris causa Joel
mr. president I have the honor to
present Bernard Bailyn for the degree of
Doctor of Letters honoris causa for
seminal contributions to your discipline
to the Academy into our society we are
honored to bestow upon you the degree of
Doctor of Letters honoris causa
mr. president I have the honor to
present Lowell Gordon Harris to accept
his degree Doctor of Letters honoris
causa is on behalf of his late father
see Lowell Harris a beloved faculty
member for more than 40 years and
forever linked with excellence at
Columbia through a professorship and two
scholarships created in his name there
could hardly be a more appropriate way
to celebrate his life than to bestow
upon C Lowell Harris the degree of
Doctor of Letters honoris costs
mr. president I now have the honor to
present Tony Kushner for the degree of
Doctor of Letters honoris causa
you have touched you have touched
countless lives with beauty honesty and
vision and for this we are honored to
present you on this stage before this
grand audience with a second Columbia
degree a Doctor of Letters honoris causa
mr. president I have the honor to
present Jacqueline Barton for the degree
of Doctor of Science honoris causa for
your transformative contributions to
human knowledge and well-being Columbia
University is honored to welcome you
back to bestow upon you another degree
Doctor of Science honoris causa
mr. president I have the honor to
present Koji nakanishi who at the last
moment was unable to be with us for the
degree of Doctor of Science honoris
causa and in recognition of your
remarkable Qi achievements that have
helped illuminate our world and your
decades of devoted service the Columbia
University we are proud to bestow upon
you the degree of Doctor of Science
honoris causa
for their outstanding contributions in
their fields but especially in the
classroom we recognize the following
faculty and present them with the
Presidential Award for Excellence in
teaching for the excellence that they
have brought to their fields and bring
every day to Columbia University we
acknowledge the following Sharon Ruth
octopus associate professor of nutrition
then Michelle s Balan assistant
professor of Social Work Linda asked
cushman associate clinical professor of
population and family health federick BS
perils associate professor of astronomy
and Michael S spare professor of health
management and health policy
the president of the University will
present the 2010 alumni medalists the
alumni will stand as their names are
announced please hold your applause
until all recipients have been
recognized we're very proud to recognize
today our alumni medalists chosen by
their peers for their efforts on behalf
of columbia as a whole Kira Tiana berry
Roger Baumann Brenda Johnson Gallagher
Barbara silver Horowitz Goodell be
horowitz Hadji me ko Sai larry lawrence
Simon kaseylee Murray o Shah Dave
Francesco and sarah shipley stone
congratulations and thank you and now a
message of congratulations from the
chair of the calumny columbia alumni
association Jim Hardin
good morning on behalf of the columbia
alumni throughout the world as chair of
the ax clumbia alumni association i
welcome you our newest members to a
network of nearly 300,000 brilliant
active graduates of columbia university
the alumni are committed to helping you
make your way in the world and we ask
that you remain connected through the
CAA to columbia and to one another
congratulations and welcome to the class
of 2010
and now the Provost of the University
will present the administrative officers
of the various divisions of the
University who will in turn introduce
candidates for the degrees in chorus in
their respective groups those candidates
will be expected to rise as they are
being introduced mr. president it is my
pleasure to present mechele moody Adams
Dean of Columbia College
Columbia College Peace Prize mr.
president standing before you today are
the illustrious the scintillating the
dazzlingly distinguished candidates of
columbia college class of 2010 they have
navigated to challenging waters of the
core curriculum steering a careful
course between the Scylla of mindless
memorization and the Charybdis of
pompous erudition they have they have
negotiated the pathways of college walk
surviving broken heels and twisted
ankles and the slings of outrageous
fortune as they grapple with Dante
Cervantes and Cod they have met the
exacting standards of our faculty of
arts and sciences combining the wisdom
of the ages with a thoroughgoing
appreciation for the mighty challenges
of the global future mr. president in
recognition of their extraordinary
accomplishment I ask that you award the
degree of Bachelor of Arts to these
candidates of columbia college class of
and that you grant them all the rights
privileges and responsibilities attached
ok
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present Phineas key pen amaura Dean of
the fou foundation school of engineering
and applied science
remember that you want to get out of the
rain mr. president before you stand
exceptional candidates of the faculty of
the full Foundation School of
Engineering applied science they're
socially responsible engineering and
applied science leaders whose work will
resort in the betterment of the human
condition locally nationally and
globally these talented men and women
had the excellence and leadership to
make an impact that will fulfill all one
of the original missions of the King's
College of 1754 to provide everything
useful for the comfort the convenience
and elegance of life they have completed
the requirements prescribed by the
Faculty of the Pooh Foundation School of
Engineering applied science for the
degrees of Bachelor of Science masters
of science
professional engineering degree and
doctor of engineering science I
respectfully request you sir to please
confirm upon them these degrees with all
the rights and privileges thereto
attached
you
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present Deborah spar president of
Barnard College
mr. president it is my honor and my
pleasure to present to you the brilliant
the bold the slightly rain-soaked and
yet still ever beautiful women of
Barnard College
under the watchful eye of Nike with the
leadership of Athena and in the splendor
of the Diana they they have completed
the requirements prescribed by the
Faculty for The Bachelor of Arts degree
and so I ask you please to confer these
degrees along with the rights
responsibilities and privileges thereto
attached
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present Peter on Dean of the School of
general studies mr. president to your
right and perch to an Olympian Heights
stand the urbane intellectually
sophisticated and deeply indebted
candidates of the faculty of the school
of general studies the most
distinguished college in the country
designed specifically for students who
take an untraditional path to a
traditional and rigorous Ivy League
education these exceptional these
exceptional women and men have completed
the requirements prescribed by their
faculty for the degrees of Bachelor of
Arts and Bachelor of Science I beg you
sir to grant them these degrees along
with the rights and privileges thereto
attached
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present Christine bill meier dean of the
school of continuing education mr.
president standing before you to your
right are the alarmingly intelligent
endlessly committed and assiduously
entrepreneurial candidates of the
faculty of continuing education these
candidates come forth from the youngest
of the schools at our great university
but they represent the focal point of
education in our still young century to
transform knowledge and understanding in
service of the greater good president
Bollinger I certify that these students
have completed the requirements
prescribed by the Faculty of continuing
education for the degree of Master of
Science in the following emerging and
evolving fields of study actuarial
science construction administration
fundraising management information and
digital resource management landscape
design negotiation and conflict
resolution sports management strategic
communications and technology management
through their endeavors these candidates
have developed into citizens of the 21st
century continuing to grow and reinvent
themselves knowing because the doors of
wisdom are never shut that they will
never stop learning I beseech you sir to
grant them this degree along with the
rights responsibilities and privileges
thereto attached
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present Carol Becker Dean of the School
of Arts
hi everybody mr. president before you
way over there stand the fabulously
talented candidates of the Faculty of
the School of the Arts in film theater
writing and visual arts they represent
most parts of the United States as well
as 23 countries they have dazzled amused
terrified astonished and surprised us
and each other with their boundless
enthusiasm and creativity miraculously
while succeeding at all this they also
have completed the requirements
prescribed by the Faculty for the
degrees of Master of Arts and master of
fine arts I implore you mr. president to
grant them these degrees along with the
rights and privileges thereto attached
so that they may go out into the world
as have the courageous artists we have
honored today Dana shuts Tony Kushner
and Zhu Bing and struggle against all
odds to be appreciated by society as
they so generously continue to challenge
and entertain us in multiple forms and
give voice to the brilliance of their
generation thank you
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present John Coatsworth Dean of the
School of International and public
affairs
mr. president
to your left
to your extreme left stand the
candidates of the faculty of
International and public affairs who are
who are committed to sustainable
development social justice democratic
governance and a world at peace in short
they are passionate about their
international affairs great lovers great
lovers of public service and undaunted
by earthquakes and raindrops
and they have completed all of the
requirements prescribed by the Faculty
for the degrees of Master of
International Affairs and Master of
Public Administration I beg you sir to
grant them these degrees with all the
privileges and rights pertaining thereto
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present genetic immoral dean of the
school of social work
mr. president the candidates of the
Faculty of Social Work for the master of
science and dr. social welfare degrees
are exceptional in every Columbia way
intelligent gifted sophisticated
cosmopolitan highly skilled rain or
shine they gave half a million hours to
note to new york city our nation and the
world they've worked at the Screen
Actors Fund in corporate HR departments
at the UN the New York Presbyterian
Hospital the International Rescue
Committee sanctuary for families and
more they came to change the world and
they will with enormous pride sir i beg
you to grant these exemplary candidates
these degrees along with the rights and
privileges they are too attached
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present IRA Lamster Dean of the College
of Dental Medicine
small in number but strong of spirit mr.
president before you stand the
candidates of the Faculty of the College
of Dental Medicine who have completed
the requirements prescribed by that
faculty for the degrees of Master of
Science and Doctor of Dental Surgery
these graduates represent the future of
dental medicine and carry with them our
hopes and expectations for the continued
development of our profession these
individuals are best described as
socially conscious dedicated
collaborative and compassionate many in
this class have traveled locally and
globally to provide oral health care
services to those in greatest need they
now continue on in their education at
the finest residency programs in the
United States in addition to all of
these wonderful attributes members of
the College of Dental Medicine class of
2010 also demonstrates superb oral
hygiene and are of course completely
painless I beg you mr. president to
grant theam these degrees along with the
rights and privileges thereto attached
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present our Glenn Hubbard Dean of the
Graduate School of Business
mr. president before you stand before
you stand mr. president the soaking with
opportunity the entrepreneurial the non
bailout receiving candidates of the
faculty of business take stock of my
bond sir except my warrant and look on
with interest and please I beg you grant
them the degrees that they have earned
with the rights the responsibilities and
the privileges thereto attached
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present Nicholas lemon Dean of the
Graduate School of Journalism
mr. president they tell me you've been
going around saying you'd like the press
to be uninhibited robust and wide open
sir if that's what you really want you
need look no further than those stands
to your right we're proudly stand the
candidates of the faculty of journalism
they are more uninhibited than Lady gaga
they are more robust than iron man they
are more wide-open than loving County
Texas where I once had to do a story
population 42 in addition they are
digitally adept platform agnostic and
richly interactive and it and besides
all that their weather resistant
if you were not a lawyer sir I would not
be entirely confident that it's legal
for one small category of humanity to be
so unfairly blessed with such potent
capabilities but since you say it's okay
indeed essential to the success of
democracy then I humbly beseech you to
grant them the degrees of Master of
Science Master of Arts and Doctor of
Philosophy along with the rights and
privileges thereto attached
she's next
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present Susan Fuhrman president of
Teachers College
Oh
mr. president standing very loudly to
your left stand the candidates of the
Faculty of Teachers College who have
completed the requirements for the
degrees of Master of Arts Master of
Education Master of Science and doctor
of Education they are schooled and
schooling educated about educating
intense about innovation and informed
about reform I beg you sir to grab them
these degrees along with the rights and
privileges thereto attached
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present mark Wiggly Dean of the Graduate
School of Architecture planning and
preservation mr. president before you
stand the candidates for the faculty of
architecture planning and preservation
it's obvious to everybody here these
people are embarrassingly intelligent
relentlessly experimental and routinely
fashionable these are the people who
want to change the way that we live and
the way that we think they have digital
streams flowing through their veins they
have new materials at their fingertips
they have brilliant brilliant vision in
their heads in their hands in their life
and they're itching to make a huge
impact in every corner of this planet
and for sure they will mr. president
it's time to launch these heat-seeking
heat-producing designers and developers
into the world they have completed the
absolutely torturous requirements
prescribed by the Faculty for the
degrees of Master of Architecture Master
of Science in advanced architectural
design urban design historic
preservation urban planning and real
estate development I beg you sir to
grantham these degrees along with the
rights privileges responsibilities
thereto attached
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present David scissor Dean of the School
of Law
mr. president for you Stan the
boisterous even loud candidates of the
Faculty of Law who have completed the
requirements prescribed by the Faculty
for the degrees of juris doctor Master
of Laws doctor of the science of law
they are exceptionally talented
extremely well-trained prepared to
advance the cause of justice they've
given new meaning to the phrase bar
review and they are ready to join you
mr. president as graduates of Columbia
Law School I beg you sir please grantham
these degrees
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present Lee Goldman executive vice
president of health and biomedical
sciences and Dean of health sciences and
medicine
mr. president
I'm so proud to present the candidates
of the Faculty of Medicine of Columbia's
College of fabulous physicians and
superb surgeons there's sometimes
boisterous sometimes sleep-deprived but
I can guarantee you they've mastered the
anatomy and physiology critical for all
lovers of the medical profession they've
also mastered the scientific knowledge
clinical skills and professionalism to
be able to improve the health and
welfare of their patients I realized
that this morning they may seem slightly
wet behind the ears but I can guarantee
you that they have completed or exceed
the prescribed requirements the degrees
of Master of Science Master human
nutrition dr. physical therapy match of
occupational therapy and Doctor of
Medicine our respectfully request sir
that they'd agree on these degrees along
with all the rights and privileges
thereto attached
mr. president as you know Columbia was
the first university in America to grant
the MD degree some 240 years ago as is
our custom I request your permission to
administer the Hippocratic oath to those
to whom you've just granted the doctor
of medicine degree now although they're
prepared to recite the oath and Greek
this morning going to do it in English
so please join with me graduates I
solemnly swear by whatever I hold most
sacred that I'll be loyal to the
profession of medicine and just and
generous to its members now I will lead
my life and practice my art in
uprightness and honor their torso house
I shall enter it shall be for the good
of the sick to the utmost of my power
holding myself far aloof from wrong from
corruption and for the tempting of
others device but I'll exercise my art
solely for the care of my patients and
will give no drug or perform no
operation for an unworthy purpose even
if solicited far less suggested that
without so ever I shall see or hear the
lives of my patients which are not
fitting to be spoken I'll keep enviably
secret I ask you to bow your heads if
you remain true to this your oath the
good repute ever be yours the opposite
if you shall prove yourselves forsworn
congratulations and welcome to the
profession of medicine
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present Mary Londoner Dean of the School
of Nursing
mr. president before you stand the
newest Columbia members of the nation's
most precious resource nurses who will
fulfill the comprehensive health care
needs of every individual they care for
they will do so through expert clinical
practice and through the science of
their extraordinary research they have
completed the requirements for The
Bachelor of Science Master of Science
Doctor of Nursing science Doctor of
Philosophy and Doctor of Nursing
Practice degrees please sir Grantham
these degrees along with the rights
responsibilities and privileges thereto
attached you may need a nurse
mr. president it is my pleasure to
present Linda free Dean of the mailman
school of public health
mr. president before you on the far
right with their feet planted firmly on
the ground and their eyes on the cosmos
as well as the health impacts of climate
change stand the relentlessly global
socially committed politically astute
diverse and stupendously brilliant
candidates of the mailman school of
public health sir these candidates
hailing from nations around the world
must not be detained from their noble
mission of preventing disease improving
health creating the health systems of
our future in every quarter of our
planet they have completed the
requirements prescribed by their faculty
for the degrees of Master of Public
Health Master of Science and doctor of
Public Health I beseech you sir to
grantham these degrees along with the
rights and responsibilities thereto
attached
last but not least mr. president it is
my pleasure to present Henry pinkham
Dean of the Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences mr. president before you stand
the wet and cold candidates of the
Faculty of the Graduate School of Arts
and Sciences who are sufficiently well
educated not to be cheap puns or empty
superlatives to accompany them on this
day they have repeated requirements
prescribed by that faculty for the
degrees of Master of Arts Master of
philosophy Doctor of Philosophy and
Doctor of Musical Arts I ask you sir to
grant them these degrees along with the
rights privileges and responsibilities
thereto attached
now will all candidates for degrees in
course rise for the conferring of
degrees by the president
the appropriate academic authorities
have determined and have so reported to
me that these students who have
satisfactorily completed the course of
study prescribed by the Faculty under
which they have each been enrolled as
candidate for a university degree in in
accordance with the authority vested in
me as president of the University I now
admit each of you to the degree for
which you have been qualified in token
whereof you will subsequently receive a
diploma congratulations to the car
you
if if ever there were a day if ever
there were a day to thank your parents
and families this is it please turn
around and thank your parents and family
so have a fabulous life
will everyone please rise and join the
clef hangers and the Columbia glee club
in singing of Stan Colombia please
remain standing until after the closing
words by the chaplain Janelle Davis
light super know in my rage as we see
light torchlight children's legs to
kingdom begun start to cheer by San
colombiana martyr the storms of time by
Stan Colombia
water through the storms of time by
raishin eyebrow and you're grateful
generation healthy as we healthy now
till the morn B and C word sister is
here hi Stan Columbia alma mater through
the storms of time I sang Columbia on
the water through the storms of time
come back to Columbia often to refresh
your spirit and renew your mind now go
and get warm and dry Godspeed